[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
what is going on y'all it's a little
dark in here let me turn this
up let's get this going
well you know it's gonna get brighter
when the sun comes out
um
what's going on guys what is going on
maybe we got to get some lights on here
boom let's get some front light let's
crank this up a little bit this is all i
got for y'all at the moment
okay because we're gonna be in metahuman
today all right
welcome back everybody good to see y'all
thanks for joining me on the saturday
live streams i do it every single
saturday you guys know this
um yeah cg stuff usually cinema 4d
sometimes
unreal engine you know but today is a
special day because
meta human came out this week
specifically the early access beta
now i would love for you guys to join me
i know some of you
might have the early access there's a
link in the description below
that will get you guys to the page here
let me actually just show you
uh what this looks like real quick let's
see let's see
so if you go to the link in the
description below it's the first link
you're gonna go here and you're going to
request
access um i think you need an unreal
engine
like an epic games account but it's all
free everything's free i don't know how
long it takes for you guys to get access
to this
if it takes if it's instant or if it's a
you know half a day or something
um but basically it'll take you to this
screen here
where you can you know start building
out
your metahuman and that's exactly what
we're doing so
let's just frickin jump into it guys i'm
so excited for this because you can
actually use
qixel bridge to export these characters
and bring them into your scenes it
doesn't matter if you're like in you
know 3ds max or cinema 4d or unreal
engine
the cool thing about this is one they
look beautiful
you know here let's go to let's just
pull up one of these
we're going to get into all of this guys
i'm going to show you every little
slider every little knob that works in
this thing
and it's really cool but basically you
can hook it up to
facial capture and have it like actually
track your lips and everything
um let's just pick let's pick this old
lady right here
and you can preview it you can like
change it to the face
rom and you can see how the face moves
and everything
it's absolutely crazy
yeah cinematic captures yeah um i've
been playing around with it too man it's
really cool
this week has been a fun one because
we've been waiting for this for a long
time
as you guys you know as much much of you
guys have been waiting for this it's
been really cool it's been a long time
coming
um i'm just ready for this for the full
thing to come out this is still in beta
but
it looks so good if you hold l and move
your mouse around you can change the
light
shift l will reset it and you can switch
to
like an indoor lighting style you can
switch to
outdoor lighting style and a silhouette
if you just want to focus
on the shape of the face and that's what
we're going to be doing today because
i'm going to be
recreating myself in metahuman
we're going to see how close i can get i
tried it before
the stream um kind of experimenting
earlier in the week and it's difficult
it's certainly difficult you don't have
full control over all these sliders but
i i have a feeling that i can do it
if i just if if we use reference
correctly um and if we
really pay attention to the details and
that's exactly what we're going to be
doing so
let me um let me first load up my
reference okay so i'm going to go back
to the meta human
home button here top left
and i'm going to open pure ref okay
and i'm going to drop some images in
that i took earlier today
let's see here
all right so these are all goofy images
of me
that look absolutely ridiculous but
it's what we need
to recreate myself in this program so
you know we got
classic um front on and profile view
that's going to help us there and then i
also have
let's see let's go fronton we have a
grimace
we got a mouth open a little bit more
and we have mouth open a lot
and same for the side view mouth open
a little bit mouth open a lot i have no
idea why these pictures are larger
um let's see
and there's one more this guy right here
nope that's the same one
i don't think it really matters
too much that works for us though that
works for us
so in pure f let's go ahead and control
p
all these guys so they uh kind of even
out
actually no no we want to go images
align uh arrange what is that selection
canvas how do you arrange them all by
size
arrange normalize
the size yes
here we go now we can arrange these
for best reference here boom boom
and boom sweet so we're going to be
using this
to try and create myself in this program
and then we'll get crazy with it and
we'll make some ridiculous characters
all right so let's just start with a new
one i'm gonna move this over to the side
here
um and let's see what we can do here
let's uh let's create a metahuman
and embark on this journey so if you
guys have
this program if you guys are in early
access
give me a little thumbs up let me know
if you are joining me on this adventure
and if you're going to be creating some
meta-humans otherwise if you're just
going to be enjoying the video give me a
little smiley face
but regardless we're gonna have a good
time and we're all gonna learn a little
something
okay so obviously i'm a white dude
so we gotta find a white dude um and
there's a couple
in here and i need to find the one that
looks
the most similar to me um
you know like there's this dude etor
but i don't know it kind of looks like
uh
looks like johnny bosworth a little bit
and i get johnny bosworth vibes and
and uh edward from
from twilight a little bit you know
let's see let's keep going mr miyagi
all right um
this guy nasim definitely not on nasim
now omar kind of looks like my brother
and i might just go off of this omar
model right here i think this might be
the best way to go so
yeah a lot of you guys got the thumbs
ups going um
which means you guys are in metahuman
right now and that is awesome
i love it keaton yo thank you for the
super chat
uh he says the the series is helping you
not give up on learning 3d for games
because it's hard dude yes it is so hard
but man you got to keep it consistent
you got to keep it consistent so i'm
proud of you for coming back here and
joining me
every week i think you were here last
week too man keep it up keep going
and you know to all of you guys who are
struggling with the 3d thing
like keep it up just keep it up okay i
promise that
if you stay consistent with something
you're gonna get better at it
that's just a given right that's an
obvious thing but it's hard to do
it's really hard to do um
all right uh arturo what's up dude yo
thank you
for the super chat he said try it or
omar easy start i played around with
many human creators the past couple days
it's a great tool
yeah i'm gonna start with omar i think
omar looks similar to my brother
um so i think this is a this is a great
start for us
i'm just gonna hit next and we're going
to get right into
creating this thing right so for me
i'm using a pen tablet a wacom pen
tablet here
we have all the instructions on the
right side
all the hotkeys which i think you can
hide by toggling it up here this
little uh you know keyboard icon
and i'm using one two three four and
five to switch
my different uh my different camera
angles and stuff but
number one is the main one we're gonna
be up here and if you just left click
to any point on the body it's gonna move
that uh the camera to focus on that
point and then obviously you can left
click and drag to reveal you know
different
different looks and stuff okay
so let's let's jump into this thing um i
i have hair
all right so let's let's throw some hair
on me the head
yeah the head option let's see what we
got a fro
what do i look like with a fro
boom that's great that's so cool
oh man look at that look how like
detailed the hair is it's crazy
that's absolutely insane there's a salt
and pepper slider
you know get that salt and pepper going
dude we got 900 people up in the stream
today guys thank you so much
that is awesome freaking sweet we're
making
metahumans today i'm going to try and
recreate myself
in metahuman i got these references and
we're gonna
we're gonna do it you know and then
we'll make some crazy stuff
but let's see um my hair
right now it's kind of you know i got
the part going
this might this might be a thing i don't
have that much gray so let's get that
salt and pepper down
just a little bit i think this hair is
probably close
closest to my hair um
it's just not as light brown
i don't know um so let's go into the
color and maybe take some of the redness
down and the
melanin melanin slider yeah
let's get that maybe something like that
and then i believe we have
options on the roughness yeah so you can
make it shinier
or a little bit more rough so probably
somewhere in here
and again based off the reference
you know the hair my hair is a little
darker
so maybe we get the melon in the slider
up a little bit something like
that maybe
i don't really have any redness in my
hair
but maybe mixing a little in could help
it's still a little like
take down the roughness just a little
bit
and just kind of dial this in like
that's that's probably close
enough i'm cool with that
all right so moving on let's go to the
eyebrows
the eyebrows my eyebrows kind of like
they're thick right up in here
kind of a little unibrow going on and
then it goes
down to the side it tapers off very
skinny to the side
and guys we have 1 000 people up in the
stream right now
we're streaming metahumans it's amazing
um this is the second time we've ever
hit over a thousand people guys so
thank you for helping me set records
this is great
all right so my eyebrows they're a
little bit brighter this dudes eyebrows
are kind of
on the dark side um so
maybe we just brighten these bad boys up
a little bit
100k yeah let's go
all right um
all right this dude needs to chill well
maybe i don't know it looks better when
he's moving around
to be honest that's not bad right there
that's not bad the eye color look at
those eyes i don't have those color eyes
i got like turquoise eyes
so let's hit up the eyes let's go to the
eyes i'm just kind of working my way
down
um what do we think something like this
let's get up in there
and i'm actually going to pause this
animation
so we can focus on the eye just a little
bit more
um like that looks pretty freaking close
to me
let's hit up that iris we can change the
type of iris here isn't that insane
and then you can change the the color
balance between
the two colors here so the color balance
smoothness if i crank that
is it all the way up no it's the
blend method structural let's see
let's just go from the bottom so the lim
the limbus darkness
guys you can control the limbus darkness
it's ridiculous
um that's just the outside of the eye
you know mine's probably it's kind of
dark a little something like that
the iris saturation pretty
straightforward
you know something
like that the iris size
cool cool um the color balance
smoothness
so i think the colors between these two
are very similar
so it's not doing that big of a
difference here the color balance if we
now these sliders aren't doing too much
for us
right and you can actually adjust the
other eye
as well so you can go to the left eye
you can go to the right
eye and adjust those different things so
i'm going to go to both
in the base color i'm just going to take
this to more of a
brighter
saturated
something like that and crank the
saturation
like that feels pretty good to me and
then let's just mess with like the the
iris shape here too which is
freaking crazy it looks like a pool
like this one's pretty good i like this
one
awesome awesome awesome so hit one
it'll take you back to this let's hit
play and just kind of move it around a
little bit
awesome very cool so i think my hair is
probably a little less saturated but we
can go we'll do another pass on it
um how you guys doing you guys chilling
out having a good time
thank you for joining me thanks for
hopping in we i'm creating myself a
metahuman right now we got
a super chat from mr evolver interactive
thank you sir you've been around for a
long time i appreciate you
um he says it's amazing how accessible
technology has become omniverse
audio to face was released to public
um omniverse that's the uh
is that the nvidia plug-in that allows
people to like work together seamlessly
because i'm very excited about that i
got that downloaded and ready to go
and i'll be probably doing some streams
with that pretty soon and john hey i see
you man
um sorry i missed the chat though so you
said watching since 2009 that's a long
time that's like
since carbon warfare he said you
inspired me to make films as a kid it's
my first feature coming out this year
and i have yourself in quarter crew to
thank holy crap dude
that's awesome yo hit me up on discord
man i'd love to watch it
congratulations that's a huge feat i
know i'm i'm trying to
trying to do that myself and it's tough
yo we got devon in the chat what's up
devon
devon williams one of my very best
friends holding it down in atlanta
georgia
while i'm out here in los angeles
i hope to see you soon devon i miss you
man
all right all right son it's a brand new
day son
davon did you get the brett driver
t-shirt the what up sun shirt
i got mine yesterday i got my hoodie i'm
excited
all right let's keep going all right
let's keep let's keep moving on this
thing
kanban what's up thanks for the super
chat that's great
um so today you got hired by a theater
company to do their designs and lighting
production
thanks for all the tips and streams
congratulations on the job
i'm excited for you you're going to
knock it out man very very cool
sweet sweet sweet we got a lot of good
people up in here right now guys
we got people from all around the world
this is awesome let's keep going let's
keep going
so i'm kind of pale in this photo
um it could be the lighting it could
certainly be the lighting
um but let's go to the skin tab
and see what we can do about this skin
tone
the color of the skin let's click this
oh we gotta stop the animation
hit the stop button there and
definitely not a vampire
that's super intense um somewhere
and
like this range but i feel like it's
again it's the lighting here that's
it's giving me that kind of pale look
maybe like i don't know this is a tough
one
this is a tough one
so it's changing the lips too and it's
tough to see like is it changing the
lips
or is it just the color of the skin
uh let me reset this let's see how would
i reset um just ctrl z
all right so if i just wanted to
make myself a little bit more pale
i'll just crank that u slider back a
little bit
and like that's not that's not bad we
can always revisit it
i don't know if you can edit the scene
lighting color i know you can change or
let's
get that epic ray trace lighting going i
know you can change the lod
dude what if you look like this this is
amazing so this is what gets me amped
about this program by the way
um like i want to do a short film
with a character like this this just
makes me laugh if you go to the teeth
it'll actually make him grimace
and you can open his mouth and stuff um
yeah pretty terrifying pretty terrifying
oh i love it i love it um we'll get into
all of this dude
this is so good you know hold on
i gotta do it you know
ah this is perfect like this kills me
i really want to do something with this
make some sort of janky character
maybe this is how i do that janky chan
short film you know
we'll figure that one out
all right so let's let's change the
lighting here
i really prefer we actually know what
indoor might be the best way to go
because i took
my photo indoors um
so let's
let's line this up again
so it's a little brighter i think you
can change ooh the blur amount
you can change the blur amount
interesting
very cool all right so let's uh let's
keep moving shall we
um so the lighting on the eyes the eyes
seem a little dead a little dark
um
[Music]
but that's okay i think that's okay
that's probably due to
just the lighting here so the studio
light is probably my favorite again you
can hold
l and move this uh move this around
and the lighting will change dynamically
very cool shift l resets it
but maybe i don't know maybe we do go
back to indoor
we can stop the animation
and let's get out let's get out of the
teeth let's um
actually know what screw it we're on the
teeth let's do the teeth
carillo tron what's up dude thanks for
the super chat
i appreciate you um you say
clint do you really have two symmetrical
birthmarks
on your forehead judging by the photo
do i i don't know um are those freckles
are freckles birthmarks i don't know i
guess so
all right let's see if we can get his
teeth my teeth definitely are jacked up
so let's see if we can't jack these
teeth up a little bit
um so
the plaque amount you can crank that
and i don't think i have that much but
maybe there's a little bit
a little something okay and the
the teeth here you see all these sliders
up here you can move all these around
to shift things and like do some cool
stuff so
let's see what we can do
all right so all of this stuff here the
overjet
the the poly cane the overbite that's
all controlled by these sliders up here
so instead of going and doing this
little drop down let's just work these
sliders
so spacing and my teeth are pretty
oh it even like crunches that bottom
tooth in i like that
if you get them like really crunched up
against each other over jet
maybe that's a side view angle thing um
what if we
come at it from the side here what does
overjet do
so overjet kind of like tilts the teeth
a little bit
luckily i have some side view going on
here
and it looks like my teeth
let's see let's make this a little
smaller
i think this is an all-time record we
got 1100 people
freaking crazy thank you guys for
joining me this is awesome
um nerps thank you for the super chat
lod7 makes it look like sloth from the
goonies
yes that is exactly what my fiance said
and i want to create
sloth once i finish creating myself here
i think that'll be really fun i just
want to make something like nasty
looking
so let's get that over jet slider going
i feel like
i am all the way to the left on that
tooth length
do i have long teeth how long are my
teeth they're kind of long
i don't know maybe that long upper shift
so that shifts it left and right
let's see if there's any more side view
um adjustments
that we can utilize here receding gums
no
narrowness i think there's an overbite
option
where's that overbite option poly cane
tooth length upper
overbite here we go so i have an
overbite
for sure um so that actually
kind of works out and the overjet maybe
we can yeah still crank back
derek thank you for the super chat much
appreciated brother
not even a text message with it man just
the super chat thank you so much
maybe i do have some salt and pepper in
my hair um
but let's stay focused as focused as we
can here
let's go back to the front angle just
hitting one on the keyboard and that's
going to take me back to the front
let's see if we can't find
boom there we go
so my teeth are a little bit more
a little bit more jacked up here um
wondering if how can we do this how can
we do this
lower shift so maybe get some shift
going on the teeth there
just a little bit
um upper shift you know i'm not like tom
cruise i don't got the freaking
middle tooth thing going so we don't
need to crank that too much
um
[Music]
let's see um the killer mambo asks how's
life been
after going solo i'd like to hear about
it man it has been
fantastic yeah um so most of you guys
probably know at this point i left
corridor
about a month ago um the reason was
because i have a lot of things that i
wanna do
there's personal passion projects that i
gotta knock out
um this channel being one of them i
wanna do more videos for you guys
teach you guys everything i know and
learn and grow with you guys that's the
whole point of this channel right now
um there's just a lot going on man i got
the whole discord thing going we nearly
have 14k
people on the discord we're doing weekly
challenges every single week
um we're all just getting better at our
craft together i want to do a feature
film
um i'm doing a community render
challenge announcing that
this month okay or like technically
i'm announcing it may 1st all right the
next community render challenge
so get ready for it it's going to be
amazing i can't wait for you guys to
participate
there's going to be some incredible
prizes for the top five winners
i'm not going to tell you what the
prizes are now but i'm telling you it's
going to be insane
okay so don't miss out if you guys want
to
join this thing definitely subscribe uh
click the bell notification icon you
guys know how this stuff works
but yeah man it's been awesome it's it's
allowed me to focus on
the stuff i have been wanting to do for
a long time
so i'm digging it i'm digging it a lot
all right let's get these teeth done so
we can get these goofy faces off the
screen
um poly cane what is poly cane
maybe i have some of that i don't know
what that is it's like
sharp teeth or something i got a little
sharp sharpness into my teeth
gabriel palmis thank you for the super
chat
heck yeah critical hit son absolutely
narrowness yeah my teeth kind of like
they come in
they definitely come in
yeah um worn down okay
i definitely don't look like this okay
that's that that's a thing i don't
i don't got the worn down teeth so we'll
put that all the way down to the bottom
all right all right upper shift tooth
length we did all this stuff
maybe tooth length will take back up to
the top
um over jet one is over jet
we talked about that went that far to
the left
i think we're good here um
tooth wise i believe what about those
lips though
um tooth color
probably feels right gum color could
maybe
come up a little bit
pink or light pink
i don't know maybe pink
something like that
awesome awesome and we can also you when
when you close the jaw that's the
overbite that's the super series
overbite but i don't have that
i don't know do i can't tell
where's that overbite at poly kane tooth
length
receding worn down narrowness over jet
overbite
so like i kind of have the overbite it's
like a mix you know it's certainly a mix
so what if we just did that face rom we
load up the face rom hit play and we see
what
it looks like
so it's the eyes they feel very dark to
me
um which is why i like to be in studio
mode for this stuff
devon where did i download it well
there's a link in the description you
guys got to sign up for early access
request access it's the first link in
the description and the second link in
the description will take you
to this page that i'm working on right
now once you've got the access
all right sweet still looking goofy i
love it
looking like sloth from the goonies
we'll get there i want to do that after
this here
let's go back to studio whoa
all right back to idle and
let's see if we can't get this beard
going um because the beard actually
helps
with describing the character um
let's hit that beard real quick i think
the short full beard is where i'm at
maybe it's a little longer long full
beard i definitely don't have a long
beard
yeah that's definitely not me long messy
beard
dude this is freaking cool scraggly
goatee
yeah not there yet uh medium curly beard
no not there yet um a wavy goatee
now it's a little too trimmed up what
about that chin strap
i think it's the the short full beard i
think that's where we're at
maybe work in a little bit of that salt
and pepper let's get up in here
and get that uh salt and pepper slider
up a little bit
oh we gotta stop it i guess we want to
get up in here
why is it not letting me do that listen
custom settings beard settings
so i feel like my beard is almost kind
of gray
but for whatever reason all right there
we go salt and pepper slider
just kind of cranked out a little bit
maybe crank the roughness a little bit
maybe not as much salt
something like that guys you all we are
at a all-time high 1300 people up on the
stream amazing
i'm surprised y'all are just joining me
for this man it's crazy
it is crazy up in here appreciate you
guys y'all are awesome
um for any of you all still creating
with me
who's making their metahuman give me a
thumbs up if you guys are
again just enjoying the stream give me a
little smiley face i'm curious
whoa what happened to my beard let's get
that back
and i feel like the color of this thing
needs to kind of gray out a little bit
more
um let's see
something like something like that it's
the saturation is really what it is and
i think
in the again this is a beta we're still
in beta on this right so
we're gonna have probably a ton more
options on this stuff a lot of different
accessories and whatnot so it'll happen
we'll get there we're just not there yet
let's hit that mustache okay so
the mustache bam we going long and
scraggly
a little medium curly what are we going
for long and messy
now i don't have a
like a true mustache it just kind of
connects the whole thing connects
so let's see what we can find
something that might connect all this
stuff together that's i don't know
i feel like i get it coming down the
side a little bit more long full
mustache no
that's a little too much long and messy
maybe no it's not that
medium curly
[Music]
short full long wavy i feel like long
wavy is probably
the closest i'd say
heck yeah y'all are awesome you all are
awesome
all right wider chin yeah we're going to
get into sculpting this thing in a
minute
we're almost there we got the facial
hair going
pretty nice let's uh
let's see how we're going to adjust this
so i'm matching up the eyes to the mouth
something like that
all right so now we can kind of choose
what we can do as far as the sculpt goes
all right so let me let me try and move
this guy over a little bit
awesome
okay so let's get into sculpting
let's sculpt this thing i think i need
to make this a little
smaller
and right about there it's the lips
um maybe maybe real quick before we
sculpt let's hit that skin
and adjust the
maybe we adjust the texture a little bit
so you can turn this to a freaking
old man right or you can go baby boy
right so we got to find somewhere in
between that works you know and and
where we had it before
was not the worst
right up in here is not bad but
maybe there's something a little better
i definitely know i have these guys
going here
on my eyeballs took this picture a
little bit before the stream
i woke up not too long before that so
maybe getting that in there could help
out a little bit
something like that maybe there's also
some redness you can get in the skin
um so if you go to accents you can hit
these under eye
that little under eye crank the redness
just a little bit
you know something like that crank the
lightness of that
boom i don't look like i was crying
let's also take my pupils i'm noticing
my eyes
um we want to adjust the iris size
just a little bit so i can kind of crank
those up a little
and if again if you hold l you can
adjust the lighting here
so it's certainly something like this
but
you know if we want to match it we can
go indoor
and you can't adjust the lighting here
for whatever reason
so i'll probably stick with studio i'm
just kind of going back and forth
all right
i also think we can change the whites of
the eyes
they're just very very dark and i think
this has to do with the lighting
and also the fact that it's still in
beta i think you're gonna have a little
bit more life in there
right so let's see if we can't
go to to the sky sclera
option and we can adjust the brightness
of the sclera
so we bring that up a little bit more
and we can get up in here
like really get up in here
and you can adjust like the vascularity
with the veins and stuff in there
and the rotation too it's absolutely
insane the amount of uh
the power you have
yellow yellow eyes you know irises
or sclera i guess
very cool and again you have control
over both left
and right eyeballs too
all right let's keep going um so i'm
gonna hit one it gets back to the little
face option here
and let's keep moving forward
i want to be able to move this guy a
little bit
all right we can zoom out i just want to
try and line this up again because we're
going to start sculpting the face here
in a second
his lips are too red for sure trying to
figure out how to do that
probably in makeup
and we'll go to the lips
now technically you know this isn't
this isn't makeup we're adding but i
just do want to lighten up the lips and
that might be a skin
thing i'm not really sure yet
uh joel what's up dude thank you for the
super chat i appreciate you man
thanks for joining me thanks for hanging
out
something like that complexion wise
feeling something like that
yeah and it's just those lips there that
are oh maybe we go to the lips
we take the redness down yeah there we
go
there we go saturation can come down
that feels better the lightness can come
up a little bit and this is tough
because we kind of are just matching the
lighting
at the same time um but
it's it's hard to know what's the
lighting and what is actually the color
the true color of my skin
so for that you know maybe i would like
to take a
you know a studio shot or something you
know put up the
all the aperture lights and get those
going
and try and replicate this this lighting
style
add some red back add some red back okay
let's go back to those lips let's get
that redness back up
so this is when the color blindness
comes in
maybe something like that
thanks guys awesome awesome
all right moving on
all right so you know we can get into
the body type with the shoes
and the tops and the bottoms and all
that stuff but let's
let's sculpt this thing all right so you
have these options down here we can move
all this stuff around
and then we can fine-tune sculpt so
let's start with the move tool
and see if we can't get this uh
kind of adjusting the general shapes
first and then we'll go into the sculpt
mode
and we'll get you know like the smaller
fine-tuned stuff
right so first off let me see if i can't
get this camera to
move over here i don't have a middle
click um
with my pen right now i don't have it
set up that way
let me see if i can't uh
there we go there we go
so my head feels a lot more narrow right
than this dudes
so let's get that let's get that move
tool
and let's see what we can do now this is
like
kind of like a four quadrant system and
this is pulling four points you guys can
see it's pulling four different points
and each point can get put up into left
right um like the top left top right
bottom right bottom left and anywhere in
between right so
the corners are your extremes it's it so
it seems alright
now my ears
i got some lobes certainly got some
earlobes going
and my ears are pretty close to my head
now they don't you know maybe somewhere
in there
and then we can fine tune it once we get
into the sculpt option
my nose let's see my nose
my nose
very interesting very very interesting
maybe it's up like this
a little bit and we will certainly get
into it
in that fine tune
and we're again we're just doing this
from the front we're going to go to that
side view and see what we can do the
eyeballs
my eyes the corner of my eyes kind of
come down
and i feel like my eyes are rotated
outwards
just a hair um
so i don't know how much
oh i can't wait to get to that point
we're going to do something nasty
once i get as close as i can on my on my
model here
something like i don't know something
like that
and grab the bottom of the eye too
i love it i love it
maybe something like that i don't know
um
what will i use this model for that's a
great question
that's a fantastic question i'll
probably use it for a bunch of things
man
a whole bunch of things i don't really
have any answers for it now
but um you know in the future
i my my weak point has always been
characters really
and i think this will give me a chance
to utilize some photoreal characters
into my renders
in the future here so i'm very excited
about that
so my lips the top of my lip here
it really like comes in towards itself
this little bit it comes
up and it's very sharp there
let's see if we can't get that
but the corner of the mouth opens up so
again we'll get this stuff in the fine
tune
process when we get to the sculpting
and that chin how about that chin bam
nope
somewhere in there potentially
all right let's see um
let's hit that side view let's see we
can do from the side view
carillotron thank you thank you you say
you can put your face in pure f
over the metahuman then control minus to
decrease transparency
and control t to make the window
transparent to the mouse what
okay hold on um you can put your face in
pure f over metahuman then click
control minus control minus
um to decrease transparency
and ctrl t to make the window
transparent to the mouse
oh wow okay
um the transparency how do i get back
into
shoot okay there we go control minus
that's pretty crazy um how do i get that
window
mode transparent to mouse
transparency options settings perhaps
preferences
numpad minus okay
control minus yeah there we go
oh this is weird this is weird can i
flip the image
um image
selection um
[Music]
a range i want to flip
horizontal is there a way
shift alt i don't know shift
control yeah flipping metahuman you are
right sir
uh-oh
come on met a human i believe in you
here how about this how about we get out
of the let's just go to preview
it's crunching on me
all right
dude this is next level right here i
like this
um control minus
that's creepy all right that's creepy
let's line up the eyeballs we'll take it
from the eyeballs
and i'll zoom in just a little bit
sweet we're close
all right now let's take uh
let's get this going i'm just lining up
the eyeballs this is a great move
this is a really good suggestion
all right so the eyeballs are lined up
now i just want to scale it so that my
lips
are close
there we go
dude that's so crazy okay um
let's go back to that move tool and then
you say control t
yeah all right
um dude this is this is great
something like that the eyeball
is this somewhere in there i'm very
curious to see how this works out
the nose let's get that nose out
and the lip
dude this is so cool
so we'll get into that fine tune
it's like super advanced sims
dude so crazy all right so that's the
side view we're pretty close there
now that nose definitely needs to come
out but let's go to the front view
um back to pure ref
ctrl t get that out of there
and go to the front view
i'm just lining up the pupils
as close as i can
that is trippy let's see if i can't uh
make this trans a little bit more opaque
that is weird
that is weird okay uh ctrl t
and let's adjust okay
the ears
i need to come in a little bit maybe
um the mouth
now be nice to have front and side view
at the same time
i think it's time to go into the actual
sculpting mode
to get this really spot on here
okay 1500 people that is an
all-time record here my goodness
thank you guys i appreciate you all
right ctrl t so we can get our pref back
let's bring up the opacity control plus
on the numpad
this dude looks angry now
so let's see what it looks like let's
just see what this looks like let's
preview it
and we'll we'll run it
first off let's get some clothes on this
thing let's let's deal with the clothes
here so the shoes
hmm let's get some flippy flops perhaps
um i'm always in these like
joggers so this is actually pretty
perfect
um let's go to the tops and see what we
can do
i don't know maybe a hoodie all black
hoodie
and the let's see the bottoms
let's see if we can get that khaki
that khaki look here something like that
maybe bring a little darker i wear these
pants all the time
and the shoes let's go to shoe view
i have some flip-flops very similar to
this um
boots you know i got some i got some
boots similar to this as well
but maybe we just do some nikes you know
all black nikes i certainly have those
now maybe we just do not super black but
like
close to it like a dark dark dark dark
yeah somewhere in there and then same
for this guy
we just bring that down
almost black but not quite not all the
way
so this looks nothing like me right now
this looks nothing like me right now
i swear i had can we have a bigger beard
um go to the beard short full beard is
that what we were doing
long wavy goatee
i guess it was short full beard it's the
best we got
um as far as hair goes you know there's
also a couple different options um
so go to the head and then we could do
short and messy
which might and that could work could
work
short curly fade
nah
let's get some long straight bangs going
see what that looks like
that's amazing
the hair looks so good
and then that seven boom beautiful
absolutely beautiful can't wait
we're gonna do like a really jacked up
one
that i'm very excited for
um man bun
situation double man bun ooh interesting
the hair is just insane look
how good that looks
my goodness
yeah from the side let's get uh
let's get my hair back so i don't have
these like sideburns though it's not
super
it's not as intense as that so maybe
i'll change it to short and messy
i also feel like this dude's head is
really big for some reason for his body
so let's go to the body types
um
short maybe tall
i don't know
you see that i lost the hair
maybe tall works because it makes my
head look a little smaller
all right back to studio and let's see
if we can't
get this looking a little bit better huh
let's give it a shot
all right control minus
and we'll line this up
something like this yeah
and ctrl t alright so
back to sculpting mode we're going to
get into the very specifics of all this
stuff
this is the jaw all right we definitely
want to choke this in
and down this looks like
my head is a lot more narrow than this
guy's head
maybe what we do is adjust the head
size we get the head size down and then
we adjust all these points let me try
that okay
ctrl t to disable the transparent mouse
in pure f
and whoever recommended that i really
appreciate that that's a really good one
so let's get it just the chin
to the
top of the head we'll get that correct
and it's also tough too because i feel
like
the camera angle right so my my
i took this with my iphone and i feel
like this
um is a wider angle lens this shot of me
here
so it kind of like distorted my features
a little bit this lens here
in uh in metahuman is probably looking
something like a 35
it's pretty zoomed in which means it
flattens the features of your face
yeah so
you know we have to deal with that as
well
anyway let's go back in see if we can't
get this
let's go back to yep in sculpt and ctrl
t
yx
ah c4d come on
um i don't think there's a way to change
the focal length in metahuman
all right get get so many things
close
yeah the face definitely needs to be
thinner
100 percent
i'm gonna try and get it as thin as i
possibly can
in this view
and i wonder hmm
this is probably the best way to go
lining it up to the eyes
and the eyebrows
yeah like that
so my face is actually pretty
asymmetrical
and it's cool because you can you can
adjust all that stuff here so we can
turn off symmetry
and just adjust the things per side you
know
um and i don't know why that's
uh groom's okay
just pushing pulling these points
one dead duck says i need to blend it
with one of the thinner heads
i agree yeah totally agree
um let me keep tweaking this and then
and we'll get there we will get there
and blend it with one of those
thinner heads
man this is so cool
this is a great great piece of advice
the akila something i think it was you
said to use pureref to match this up
gotta get those jaw bones popping off
all right now let's see if we can't
blend this with one of the the thinner
heads here
i think that's that's really what we
need to do so let's get uh
let's get this out of here
and get the transparency back up
know i do have a really tiny head that
is that is a thing
you know the only reason that i was shot
but in video game high school
is because i was the only guy who could
fit into that tiny helmet
so i got a tiny head very narrow
so this is kind of looking like olin
rogers a little bit right now let's see
if we can't
adjust this head so if we go to blend
we can choose between three different
heads here
and and blend them together so maybe an
etor
we drop an etore in there um
maybe a glenda i don't know let's find
out
i'm scrolling back through here we want
to find the narrowest head
possible maybe natalya
um
rosemary i don't know
yo stefan stefan's got a thin head
i like stefan's head there that's a good
one
so now what we can do is actually take
these little pieces here
and adjust them and go around this
circle
and it'll blend it to those different
heads it's actually pretty sweet
so we want to find the narrowest head
that we can possibly find
probably right in there same for here
maybe something like that the forehead
kind of got a big forehead um the chin
maybe we leave the chin
something like that perhaps
so hugo says can i suggest one thing
that
it's actually worked when i sculpt human
face try to do half a photo like hide or
cut the half of the photo
and after you tweak the asymmetric one
um
let me see if i can make sense of that
so you're saying like
like this
that's interesting very interesting yeah
okay
let's give it a shot so we'll sculpt it
and we'll make sure symmetry is on for
now
yeah i'm struggling to get that likeness
it's tough
so i want to rotate my eye like i feel
like i need to rotate it
counterclockwise just a bit but i
i can't
i'm trying to see if i hide
um what's the best way to do this
can i open another instance of puref
oh shoot oh i can okay great
so what i can do
is like hide essentially
this here
so it's the complexion yes sean bird it
is harder than i expected man
let's go to the skin and try and match
it
so
maybe something like that
no there's no color picker and there's
no like
image upload thing right now again this
is still in beta
okay um
let's see if we can get that lower half
okay i think the
contrast is a little intense
the lips turned all blue on me i think
it's the texture
yeah just go back a little bit
the nose is not bad from the bottom half
certainly not bad i think it's just the
lips
we can't get these lips down
there we go
yeah all right this is a good method
here i like this method
i want to get this bottom piece to go
down a little bit more and kind of tilt
up at the
like this shoot
it's very close it's very close
i still feel like it's the eye
that's tough you know
oh we got steve up in here what's up
steve
what's going on yeah man this is tough
very tough stuff yeah steve is uh
steve's been messing with this
as well he joined me uh last week on the
stream we made an unreal engine scene
together
super cool um so i'm sure if you guys
have any
questions that i can't see steve is uh
steve's a great resource
and rca film productions y'all
appreciate the super chat thank you
thank you
you say the textures and animation on
this are unmatched but using face
builder and blender
a one-to-one replication of your face
can be done in literally 15 minutes
i didn't know about uh face builder in
blender i don't use blender
i'm a c4d guy but that's super cool man
a lot of people here on the stream do
use blender
so that's probably a really good thing
for them to know
and yeah i just feel like metahuman is
absolutely incredible
um and i'm excited for the future
iterations because
you know i i feel like there's a number
of things i want to do but just can't
right now
um but that's okay you know we'll do our
best we're doing our very best
all right let's see
let's see
i want to get let's see let's get the
other side
so we're there let's open this up
and let's try to make this transparent
again
it's the jaw it's like i have a thinner
jaw
for sure
i also feel like the texture the skin
texture is a little off too
wondering let's see can we go something
like this maybe and we'll try it this
way
um let's go ahead and go full up on this
control plus
and i i think it also doesn't help too
that like
these are different focal lengths
that's so weird looking that's so weird
looking
i could do it from here too let's see
what this looks like
yeah that looks funky it's the camera
it's the camera angle i think
it makes it look weird it's definitely
the bottom half that doesn't look like
me
um
that's hilarious
i love it i love it agreed the whole
face is a bit too wide compared to mine
god it still definitely doesn't look
like me this is difficult
very difficult
maybe we can take the skin texture back
down again
it feels a little bit too much a little
too saturated
yeah longer and thinner for sure um
maybe the hair too
let's try a side view here and try
locking it in from a side view let's see
what that looks like um
my nose is definitely longer
and it doesn't really come up to a point
but
um that's close that's very close
my bottom lip definitely comes back a
bit more
and i have a sharper like i don't know
what that is this is definitely
rounded mine is pretty darn sharp
my bottom lip here is not bad
i don't know how to tell like
what's the best model to grab you know
um
hopefully in the future here we'll have
a thing where you can do a 3d scan of
your head
using like bellis and you can upload
that or something
could be cool
isn't it crazy guys how like
how fine-tuned and specific
our faces are and if you were to look at
this
this back to back right here i feel like
like that's actually pretty crazy
you know obviously that's me um
i'm wondering if i can do that from the
front here though that is weird
that is so weird
it's kind of there
but man this is one of the hardest
things to do
is faces
especially 3d faces you know like
drawing faces are hard getting the
likeness of somebody is very difficult
but doing this in 3d boy this is tough
i feel like the eye the eye looks like
me from the side
like that that's not bad right there
hmm yeah
so i'll take a minute here to answer
some questions in the chat
so yes i'm using pref agreed it's like
my 60
look-alike right now
um
the nose should be less less hooked and
more straight
yeah but i'm maxed out on these dang
sliders
like i can't go any further with these
things
stump thank you
i'm trying to believe in myself right
now as well
it's this freaking lip dude it's this
[Music]
lip
all right so here let me let me answer
some questions
you guys might have um let me open up a
window in here
ah thanks for sticking with me guys we
still got more than a thousand people up
in here
y'all are the best um i'll answer some
questions
take a minute to just minimize this take
a breather like one of you mentioned
and we'll hop back in in like two or
three minutes
oh all right
so yeah fajim we did the opacity setting
certainly do i use substance designer
um i i don't but i i did use it for like
two weeks it was really cool
and i want to get back into it at some
point who is my smash
main that's a great question uh it's
ness but right now
i'm meaning donkey kong um
he's a lot of fun to play so bradley
says hey clint pf has a transparency
mode might make it easier yeah we've
been on that we've been doing that kind
of going back and forth
um stump thank you for the super chat
you say what are your my
preferred tools um i'm a noob and on
windows by the way preferred tools for
what man like
i guess i use cinema 4d um that's my
go-to
i use grayscale gorilla plug-ins all the
time i use
octane um i just got into world creator
i'm using a lot of uh mega scans qixel
bridge and whatnot
uh unreal engine i'm always an unreal
engine
um what else yeah i mean i guess the
wacom tablet that's a tool
i use this all the time this glove is so
i can glide across the tablet
it helps me a lot and it keeps the oil
from my hand off the tablet makes it
easier to
to navigate is it weird having all these
people stare at my face
um no not really i'm used to it you know
i'm used to it at this point
you know just being on camera and
whatnot at rocket jump and corridor and
running on a youtube channel you kind of
get used to it christian thank you
for the super chat rock on you said i
came late but metahuman is not available
for the public to use yet question mark
you always get in the 403 era after
logging in so you need to
register for the for the beta
it's in early access right now you have
to register for early access
i think you'll get an email from them at
some point hopefully pretty soon
and then you'll be able to hop into that
second link which i have
in the description um and you'll you
know they'll probably send you an email
with all that stuff but you just gotta
register for the early access
um let's see
how do i feel about pelotina in smash
she's my favorite i don't know sam likes
palutena
but i don't know i've never never really
used her i fought against her but i
don't know much
um how much do i think metahuman will
cost when it's out it's gonna be free
all right it's gonna be free because
unreal engine is free
everything epic games is free especially
when used
with uh with unreal engine so it's just
crazy that it
that it is free and that it's super
powerful and they're adding a lot of
cool stuff to it so
it's gonna be sweet i'm very excited
about it
what's the glove for i just talked about
the glove the glove is actually so i can
navigate
and kind of glide smooth smoothly glide
across my wacom tablet
um i have one here it's connected to my
pc right now so i can only get it like
to about here but
it just helps me glide over this thing
um
keeps the oil from my hand off of it
yeah very nice
um schaefer has to leave for prom hey
good luck
good luck at prom that's pretty sweet
enjoy it
is the stream going to end i mean
eventually but not yet
you know we're probably halfway through
yeah
um what else you guys got how to make
the thumbnail
you said it's lod0 it's really fun i'll
show you that in a second
what u.s state is the best for living
[Laughter]
i don't know man i have no idea i've
only lived
seriously lived in california and
georgia
and i like them both for different
reasons
devon divon williams stream never ends
baby
heck yeah dude devon i look forward to
hanging soon man
i miss you
how's it going since i left corridor man
it's been great it's been awesome
i really enjoy uh managing my own
schedule
doing what i want to do um i love it
i absolutely love it and i still get to
hang out with those guys you know we
chill
uh pretty frequently and hang out so
it's the best of both worlds really
what are my thoughts on nerf man i love
nerf the uh the ones with like the
yellow
balls those are the best ones i love
those
what else you guys got any other
questions we'll hop back in here in
another minute
what are the differences and
similarities between character creator
and metahuman so metahuman
is fully animated everything's set up to
move with the mouth and everything
so that when you drop it into unreal
engine it just
works perfectly and seamlessly character
creator
there's a lot it's a lot more like
flushed out or fleshed out
and um there's a lot more options for
the body and for the face like i think
you can get a little
bit more detailed into the tweaking of
all that stuff
um you know you can do a bunch of
different clothes
right now metahuman is very early access
so
what you see right now is what you get
and
i'm loving it i'm absolutely loving it
it's super powerful the graphics are
insane
and i can't wait to use it in all my
renders it'll help with the story
elements and everything
and maybe eventually do some cg
characters with some dialogue and stuff
it'll be cool
matt you said the cardboard warfare got
you into vfx
uh you went hardcore and learning for
like six years but motivation went away
but
you going in your own path got me back
into vfx dude that's awesome man that
makes me really happy
yeah stick to it guys stick to it you
know if you want to get better at
something you gotta
stay consistent with it and keeping that
consistency can be pretty difficult
um certainly you know doing these
streams every single week
has been a challenge for me it really
has it's very difficult sometimes it's
very stressful
and um you know it may not seem
like it's stressful but it is you know
trying to get the stream set up and like
trying to figure out what i'm gonna do
every week on top of everything else
it's a lot
but the more i do it the better i get at
it and i feel like i'm i'm getting into
a pretty nice flow
and since i was able to leave corridor
i'm able to prep the stream on fridays
now
so i don't have to do everything on
saturday morning that's when it's just
like i'm pulling my hair out you know
getting the thumbnail uploaded and
figuring out what i'm going to do type
in the description um
adding all the art to the the art review
at the end of
these streams you know we're gonna do an
art review at the end of this stream
it's a lot to do on a saturday morning
so i kind of do that on my fridays now
so it's cool suggest a good graphics
tablet the intuos pro
man get that intuos pro i got the medium
one but they have small medium and large
it's freaking great i love it but uh hey
guys we're gonna head back in
let's jump back in yeah
all right
so this is where we're at you know like
this feels like me
this feels like me it's just the lower
half i think that's like
it's this mismatched the eyeball from
the side
looks good dude what if what if my
freaking
jaw came out this far like a mule man
like a freaking horse man
but this this looks like me it's just
here let me see about this let me see at
what point
does it not look like me anymore
i even think that looks like me
like it's freaking close
that's super close
it's just it's the lips dude
it's straight up the lips
we're gonna move all that back
more brow you think i don't know
um if i were to line this up
with my eyeball so we got to move those
lips back for sure
and maybe i need to push my eyeball
back further
yeah my eyeball needs to like go back a
little further
all right let's go transparent so uh
control
minus gets a little transparency in
there
and ctrl t will allow us just to adjust
the eyeball so let's go to the move
bits here and try and get this eyeball
back
into my face a little bit more
and the mouth gotta get that mouth
looking right i think that's the biggest
the biggest offender is the mouth
um
it just needs to be pushed back
or everything else needs to be
pushed forward um
so lining up the nose
there we go this that feels a little bit
better
all right
jeez
that looks like nick it looks like nick
now
what the heck
i just need that i need that freaking
upper lip dude
straight up this looks like nick laurent
oh boy
like dude what the chin man
that freaking chin dude why like why is
my chin so chinny
maybe i'll bring back more of the
or less of the goddamn
hmm
yeah it's like i can't i can't adjust
this
chin anymore
it just looks ridiculous now
these eyeballs dude what the heck
what the heck let's move these things
dude
no business being like that
it's really tough because like the side
view undoes the uh
the front view options a little bit
yep is focal length is the focal length
there's a few things that are hindering
me from getting any further than this
one is the fact that my head
is a little bit more narrow than this
dude's head it's a little longer too
another thing is the focal length of
the camera that i took picture myself
with from my iphone
was more of a wide-angle lens and um
the photo that we're seeing in metahuman
is a uh definitely more of
a longer lens right like a 35 or a 40 or
something maybe
what else also the fact that the sliders
i've
maxed out these dang sliders as far as i
possibly can
like that kind of looks like me
that doesn't really look like me um also
the fact that i'm missing my glasses
is a thing and i think the glasses play
a big part into
making someone look like somebody the
hair
the hair is fine i think the eyes are
worse now
god dang it
and the lips are worse it's like it's
better from the side but it's worse from
the front
you know what i mean
no no focal length in metahuman yet we
need eye rotation for sure
we need to thin out that face
do i have more of a five head like do i
have a five head i can't tell
again the focal length of the camera
makes it difficult to do
but let's see what it looks like in
motion
yeah tobey mcguire vibes i see it i see
a little bit of it
it looks like a matthew or something
if devon is still in the chat
doesn't he kind of look like matthew
just a little bit
like his eyes or something it's like the
eyes and the mouth
jake gyllenhaal i can see a little
gyllenhaal
i'm gonna do one last pass in the
eyeballs here
let's see what we can do hey now
just from the front view
all right control minus
yeah with even with my eyes that doesn't
look like me
but let's move these things around so
ctrl t on pure f
and now we can start sculpting this
thing
like how far apart are my eyes
like they why do they look so jacked up
dude i wish i could shape the beard you
know i wish i could
still early access though there's no way
like is my eye that much higher there's
there's no way my eye is that much
higher
it probably would have helped to go in
photoshop and like
try and match up uh the focal length as
well as
the you know the rotation
a little bit more
ctrl t and let's turn off symmetry
and finally let's get these lips a
little bit
i actually really liked the uh this like
symmetrical
method here i thought this was really
good
control plus
cool
this is so difficult
man maybe if i had glasses who knows
cheekbones for sure but it just makes my
head look ridiculous
[Music]
um
like a fish man
stump dude thanks for the super chat man
so hugo you say my eyes are more
rectangular shape and we have we can
almost
see the bottom of your iris this model
must have more of a round shape yes and
very close eyes
god dang this is hard i feel like i
could just tweak this for hours and
hours
so here's what i'm doing i'm gonna save
this all right by the way everything
just saves automatically
let's just create something that looks
goofy and see if we can't come back to
this
and uh maybe revisit it
let's create something new let's have
fun with this
all right
um who should we go with who should we
go with
i don't know um
let's go with glenda
let's see what glenda looks like here
and we'll hit next and let's just let's
go crazy
um jeff thank you for the super chat
you're enjoying the content maybe take
some pics from like three-quarter angle
or something
a side perspective to try to capture the
3d effect in the future
yeah man um this is very difficult
definitely biting off more than i can
chew here but you know
not bad at all i'm very impressed with
this program
and i'm excited for um for the later
versions you know
what i'm looking for is something i can
upload a 3d
like head scan or something for it to
move its points to
i feel like the points it has right now
i feel limited
[Music]
in the sense that like it doesn't give
me all the options that i have
that i need to to control my face or
maybe i just don't know the program well
enough
it just came out this week so just
something
something fun to mess around in now
let's see if uh
if we can make this look absurd
let's get let's go to skin
max out the texture
oh man rough okay uh
super shiny
arsenii thank you thank you thank you
for the super chat he says too bad that
he won't be limited to
use only an unreal engine dude i don't
think that's true man
i think you can actually use this in
cinema 4d
and i'm going to try it here in a second
let's create something nasty
um and and see if we can't load it into
c4d
um let's see it's all about the shape
here let's just start sculpting this
thing
okay that's pretty yeah i like that
very painful it looks very painful
whoa
get that chin going no chin yeah that's
the way it goes no chin
see i just want to like max this thing
out
oh my goodness
like there's probably people that look
like this you know
fish person for sure
dude what if this was your boss
are we gonna get those teeth we need
those teeth popping off
um let's hit the teeth option
whoa plaque yes
um let's just start hitting all these
sliders
uh spacing we're crunched up
customer service staff after church
jeez absolutely there yeah let's do that
like
receding gum line
just make this as jacked up as possible
tooth length
yeah i'm a fan of those tiny teeth
overbite for sure
uh tooth color oh my god
okay let's do that gum color
oh smoker for sure
freaking rough dude okay
oh all right makeup
let's get some makeup on here um
[Music]
soft and smoky yes very nice
very nice
metalness wow okay interesting lips we
need some lip
stick
oh man yeah that's the move
that's the move right there dude
united we stand join us
oh man that is intense
that's all about that that lrt seven
this is the best
like led six is half as funny
as lod7 and for those of you don't know
lod stands for level of detail
brutal
all right let's keep going um
hair what kind of hair do we want
receding hairline
or clown hair perhaps
yes yes yes yes
yes
oh that's terrifying my god it's female
larry david
[Laughter]
mohawk and bushy eyebrows okay let's try
it um
mohawk
and bushy eyebrows any other requests
now i think i think we broke it a little
bit with this
with the brows
and bring these up a little bit
an old person from cyberpunk yeah it's
the haircut for sure
try an afro okay
but whoa my goodness
so cool i love it i love it
um no hair
straight bald look look at the
performance though with the hair so this
is
um let's see if we hit the little
um we can hide the hair
and then there's a way to get uh
um what is it
performance options where are you
uh where are the performance options i
forget
oh here we go here we go the top left
let's full screen this
and it's the top left here you can pull
up the little performance options and
frame rate we got
33 frames a second here but as soon as
you throw on that hair man
like it it goes it gets choppy
let's see let's get the hair in get the
long fro going
oh that's probably another thing here
since we're in beta
the frame rate is stuck at 33 looks like
it's not updating
but you know personally i'm a fan of
the clown hair
i'm digging clown hair kind of looks
like the guy from kung fu hustle
a little bit i like that
salt it's maxed out salt and pepper is
maxed out here
eyebrows eyebrows no eyebrows now that
would be a thing
there we go
um eyelashes full on beautiful eyelashes
salt and pepper
maxed out um the beard
very interesting
very interesting i feel like no beard is
the way to go though
unless we go full salt and pepper on it
mustache like a long and scraggly
long full mustache
that is terrifying what if we take the
body type
um super skinny yep nearly emaciated
and we go like really tall that is
terrifying
could you use this for mixed reality
with vr chat i'm sure you could
yeah i'm sure you could um
[Music]
yeah the granny sweater okay what color
should we go with
like oh man like a pink or something
pink and white i don't know
pink and red
yeah it matches the lipstick alright
that's nice
try making mr bean that'd be great
uh bottoms yeah i feel like these pants
are probably the most appropriate
these ones here um
maybe like a dark blue or something
and the shoes yeah these aren't bad
um
yellow and
i don't know
i don't know something like this
violet and green okay
violet and green like barney colors
essentially
flip-flops yes
all right let's get rid of the mustache
um
god that hair is atrocious i love it
though
um let's see what other stuff we got
a short ponytail
dude this kind of looks like my boss
when i worked at a hibachi restaurant
like she had the same hair
with the eyes that don't play around um
let's sculpt let's go into sculpt mode
and see if we can get something even
crazier
yeah just permanently like permanently
angry
and then we can blend the face too with
other with other faces
everything's just cranked back here
i feel like it's a little too old so
let's
uh let's adjust the skin
yeah that's that's better that feels
better
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
i would not want to mess with this woman
very nice
freckles yes yes please
um density a lot of them
and the accents we can get the eyes
let's crank the redness
the saturation the lightness
maybe a little bit on the forehead
oh i love it i love it
and what does it look like in motion
oh i forgot about the teeth
how far can you go with skin tone no i
don't think you can do an alien but like
right now skin tone is kinda
it's just in this range here
so you can go as dark as as this
which is definitely not accurate to
anything i've seen
um kind of looks like a lizard person
but
you know i'm digging i'm digging where
we had it
right up in here you can make a tomato
let's see if we can't uh get this
working in cinema 4d so i'm going to
open cinema
and see if it's possible to export to
c4d
we'll see
tiny nose all right tiny nose let's go
uh
sculpt
and hold on let me
bring this back here
so it's unreal and maya only currently
okay
so let's see what we can do maybe i
bring this into unreal um
so this is done top right says all
changes saved
so i'm going to minimize this and let's
open up
bridge real quick quick so bridge
also free
and there's a new little tab here called
metahumans
and you know we can drop any one of
these into our scene
but my metahumans these are the ones
that we've worked on so far
yeah this does not look like me my
goodness
um glenda this is the one that we have
here glenda
and
let's go ahead and download it and see
what happens
i appreciate all you guys for joining me
on this one
it's very fun i love i love this
character crater kind of stuff
all right so i guess it's a generating i
wonder if we can
grab one of these other ones i don't
know how uh how long this takes i've
honestly never done this before
so maybe while that goes i can answer a
couple questions
from you guys all night well that does
its thing
so nick says how do you get better at
paint outs in after effects i always
find that it varies too much frame to
frame and it's jittery any insight yeah
man you just gotta
you gotta stick with it um
there's a lot of different methods for
paint outs depends on what you're
painting out too if you're painting out
a person with a moving background that
can become
very difficult you want to find your
clean plate that's essentially what
you're doing is building your clean
plate so once you can build your clean
plate then you kind of go in and like
remove the person on another layer or
remove a cable or a wire or something
um can be very difficult but i know you
can use a
there's a there's a software called
um shoot what is it called
it's an ai software it has like green
screen and stuff
um runway ml
runway ml yeah runway ml and they have
paint out
um models that you can use
and it's all automated too which is very
very cool
so felipe says it's probably easier to
create other people than yourself
because your brain doesn't let you see
yourself as other people
you're too used to seeing yourself that
i mean i'm sure that's probably
pretty close but i definitely do not see
myself in this guy
in omar um
i don't know maybe maybe i'm wrong but
it is generating it's uh 25
so i'll answer as many questions as i
can here
um and if you guys at me here in the
chat it's a lot easier for me to see
hmm
oh it was stuck at generating for you
um yesterday i guess yeah i'm in it 25
so do you think it's possible to create
a realistic homer
in metahuman maybe
that's very interesting
like doing cartoon realistic versions of
cartoon characters could be fun
actually
all right we got a lot of good questions
here
do you think it is easier for others to
make you i don't know maybe
give it a shot guys go for it see if you
can i challenge you
uh what's my favorite s24 feature well i
i hadn't used s24 yet
but i heard there is actually a feature
where it's like
a dynamic move tool where you can click
and drag
and turn dynamics on
for the objects you have selected and
when you let go dynamics turn off
and it allows you to set dress things
and like place books on a bookshelf or
something
that seems absolutely incredible there's
also a paint tool now
so you can do like a scatter tool but
with like a um with a brush
right so you're gonna paint your trees
or scatter your rocks whatever across
your scene and you can remove stuff too
so that's really awesome
very excited to jump into that i'm just
between projects right now or
i'm not between projects i'm still
working on um
actually my next nft i want to drop it
either late next week or early the week
after that
very excited about it it looks very nice
i can't wait for you guys to see it i'm
gonna do a whole
breakdown on my process on it um i can't
wait to show you the art
it's some of my best i'm very excited
about it
roundy can you change the color of
someone's sclera
absolutely if you put your mind to it
you too can change
scholar color but yes it is possible
you just go to eyes and then the sclera
option you can change the color
eric my day's going great man thank you
for asking
it's very chill
do i think there will be a generate
metahuman from
photo option in the future i really hope
so because that would make things a lot
easier and a lot more fun
then you can go crazy from there i'm
hoping that's the case
what vfx program do i recommend for
starters
okay yeah um
well blender is free so
and there's a lot of tutorials for it so
i
i mean i'd recommend blender to people
who are looking to get into vfx for the
first time or to get into 3d for the
first time who don't really know if they
want to spend money on it yet
unreal engine is also free but it's a
very deep learning curve very steep
learning curve
so i'd probably recommend blender um you
know
and from there you can explore other
options i use cinema 4d
and you know there's maya there's 3ds
max and stuff but right now it's blender
and cinema 4d are kind of the main ones
in unreal engine
and you know generating is at 75 now so
we're getting close
anything else any other questions
oh derek would i work for waeda if they
offered me something
or continue being a free agent
i think i'd have to continue being a
free agent my friend
um there's too many things that i want
to do i i didn't leave corridor to go
somewhere else i left corridor to focus
on my own stuff
so it doesn't really matter who
has you know if anyone comes to me with
a job i'm like dude
i got a lot of stuff i'm excited about i
want to put more
care more attention into you guys into
this channel
um and to everything 3d animation and
all that good stuff like i want to be
able to teach as much as i can
i want to be able to experiment and
learn with you guys as much as i can
and i want to be able to create some
really cool content and some really
awesome
short films feature films cg films like
i want to create
really cool stuff and tell cool stories
simon jones where are my nfts at well i
only have one right now
um i sold it about two months ago and
i'm on super rare
it's uh super rare dot com slash
punisher i believe or slash clinton
jones
one of those two um and i'm releasing my
second one
next week late next week very excited
about it
what other questions do we have here
glad thank you i appreciate the kind
words man i'm glad that you guys are
hanging out with me
and having a good time daniel what's up
dude thank you
for the super chat says wishing you the
best on my journey thanks for all the
countless smiles and laughs you've
shared with your work
in an outside of corridor man it means a
lot thank you so much
yeah man good stuff very good stuff
let's see let's see so
um we have downloaded successfully
downloaded
um this model here
in metahuma or in in uh in bridge
and it's just leaving me with this
option oh there we go loading
obviously see you can see i had some
funny over this guy
my shorts going to be 3d or live action
um
making a 3d short be a lot of work but
is possible
i i'd say it could be either or it could
certainly be either or
ardo what software is this so i'm using
qixel bridge
quixil bridge is um an amazing piece of
a
piece of technology here it's just a
tool that allows you to download
different textures different 3d scans
and now
digital humans so that's very very cool
all right now we're downloading this
thing probably take another minutes
let's let's answer a couple more
questions here
roy i don't think we have time for a mr
bean today but it sounds like a fun one
um maybe in the future here we'll do
that
maybe so
um hayden says what was my first
full solo project man when i was a kid
i was making little dumb short films and
those were all solo projects
um the first one i think that really was
a big deal for me
was man i i did this short
it was just a silly video really called
how to be epic and it was around the
time 300 came out
and we actually won the high school
talent show
with the video and all my friends were
in it
it's very silly you know just a bunch of
references references to stuff we were
into
when you're in high school um so that
was a that was a fun one but i think
cardboard warfare is probably the first
big one the first big solo project i did
um and if you guys don't know there's a
lot of
a lot of short films on my channel over
the last year i've been doing 3d
tutorial stuff but if you go back into
the archives
and hit those playlists you know you
guys will see
a lot of short films i did cardboard
warfare 1 1.52
2.5 it's all on the channel um
i did some more serious stuff a dead
island short film a wolfenstein
short film a sleeping dogs short film
um killzone yes thanks visual a killzone
short film that was probably one of my
favorites that i've done
um we actually were able to bring out a
pyrotechnician and blow up some stuff
it was insane it was so freaking cool
um
romer asked what's this week's weekly
challenge you want to know
you want to know don't you um yeah of
course you want to know
we'll get to in a second here let's see
what we can do with this meta human
let's see if we can get it into unreal
engine or c4d or something
and then from there i'll go into the art
review and i'll announce this week's
weekly challenge
because there's one every single week if
you guys don't know about it
we're trying to get better every single
week together so we are at 96 percent
on this download y'all
100 son 100
this is exciting i've never done this
before very cool
all right um i'm wondering if i should
just pre-open
let's do 2k resolution for now
because i think it's gonna like crunch
up the stream a little bit
so get those f's prepared all right let
me
i want to export this
there we go okay i got my export button
can i export to c4d
okay metahumans can only be exported to
unreal and maya so let's
try it let's go into unreal engine and
see what we can do
um let me open up the epic games
launcher
3am gang you guys from india how late is
it in india right now 3 am
crazy thanks for hanging out with me man
that's awesome
oh snap we're gonna go full screen for
this
sean shaman my goodness that super chat
is
very much appreciated man thank you
thank you
so you say you are a long time fan
um congratulations on your new adventure
thank you sir
thanks for years of entertainment since
the freddie w days man
god there's been so much good stuff
hasn't there been man like
i love freddy i love rocket jump and i
really miss
making videos with them and i actually
i did uh film a little something with
freddy and jimmy
for their magic the gathering thing that
was fun pretty recently
but you say been trying to grow my
channel um
help upcoming filmmakers and
photographers with basic tips and tricks
heck yeah i would appreciate a quick
shout out well dude there it is
go check him out sean shaman check out
his channel
he's trying to help you guys with uh
filmmaking tips and tricks
but i appreciate the super chat man is
very generous of you thank you so much
and mr stump that super chat is
appreciated as well thank you
6 15 a.m in australia are you
up that early my god
let me ask you guys what time is it for
y'all right now what time is it for you
guys
let me know what time it is and where
you're at i'm just curious
[Music]
but let's see here let's get uh
let's get unreal engine popping off
woo yeah
awesome awesome we got everybody in the
chat worldwide
is 11 o'clock in turkey
oh man it's flying i love it i love it
what else we got uh we got 10 16 in
germany
um 5 p.m in brazil
dang this is awesome 10 p.m
oh wow dude in the super chat i
am duet my god thank you sir
so kind of you man thank you thank you
you just want to say good luck
and you hope um hope you know how to do
your taxes
oh dude the tax video
you guys have never seen the tax video
man just freaking open up a new tab
type in freddy w taxes
and it's a video of me without my shirt
on like
freaking out i'm like freaking out and
it's just me
going crazy because i don't know how to
do my taxes
oh boy those are the days that was like
10 years ago
i didn't know how to do taxes man that
was crazy
ah but thank you for the super chat i
really appreciate it
it's nearly 2 a.m in india 120
in pakistan man that's so cool
so freaking cool worldwide here 417 and
guyana you guys are awesome you guys are
staying up late too way past that
bedtime
we got dubai ukraine what up everybody
one dead duck in the uk
10 20 in spain david sheep good to see
ya
what else 10 18 in the czech republic
what's going on
portugal 9 p.m dude
i love it freaking awesome so guys we're
just updating right now
i'm updating my unreal engine we're
going to open it up and get this meta
human in there and then we'll get this
uh
you know what screw it let's do the art
review right now let's do this art
review
right now i'll come back to this um
all right before i announce any of these
winners let me just go to studio mode
and obs
just to make sure that no one
no one's name is revealed here i want i
want this to be as
secret as possible i want to be as much
of a surprise as possible
all right so guys we're in all right
we're talking about the weekly challenge
right now this week's weekly challenge
was overgrown all right
overgrown so the prompt was overgrown
and you had to render
something using that prompt and there's
a couple things i'm looking for
when i'm judging this thing um the first
is probably render quality that's going
to be the first thing that catches my
eye as your render quality
the second is probably gonna be um
composition and visual aesthetic like
how
how nice does it look which one catches
my eyes i'm looking through these
submissions
and then finally well not finally but
most importantly is story does your
render have a story to it and then i'd
say most importantly does it follow the
theme
of overgrown all right so i used
basically those four
things um render quality
how closely does it follow the prompt um
is there a story in your render and
uh does it look visually appealing how's
your composition and all that good stuff
right so that's what i'm looking for
on these submissions here and real quick
gotta say
to arseney i appreciate the super chat
thank you sir
always you said always was wondering
when they show bts footage green screen
almost always doesn't cover 100
background why then
do you green screen oh that's a good
question
that's a really good question so let me
just answer this question real quick
it's a good one
the question is if if i were to have a
green screen behind me right now
why does the green screen not cover the
entire background
but why why is it just limited to me
well that's because when you removing
the green
in that green screen um
you're gonna you're gonna essentially
the point of a green screen is to remove
a person from the footage as opposed to
having to manually rotoscope a person
right um the green screen makes it easy
to do that to
pull me out from the footage i only need
a green screen over the area
i'm trying to extract so
i don't need a massive 20 foot by 20
foot green screen for a person
in a wide shot i just need a person's
worth of green screen to remove that
person
all right so it's a way to save money
and we don't all have 20 foot green
screens you might have a pop out green
screen that'll cover your body
or the thing you're trying to remove but
you don't need to cover the whole thing
because later in after effects you'll
draw a garbage mat around it and you'll
just remove the stuff
that's easy really good question really
really good question and thank you for
the super chat
um and and ours not ours simon
i appreciate you thank you sir also you
say shout out to you and all the
argentinian people in the chat
love the corridor stuff and your
tutorials are amazing first donation of
my life my god sir thank you
thank you it means a lot first donation
of your life
to the server to the freaking live
streams man thank you thank you thank
you
all right guys shall we get into the art
review i think it's time
i think it is time indeed okay guys
like i said the prompt
was overgrown okay
so let's do it the first winner of the
weekly challenge
who will get the weekly challenge winner
role
is are you ready
boom right here this is uh
utkarsh kumar singh probably butcher the
name a little bit apologies but
man is this a nice render
it has amazing render quality
fantastic composition it has a story
and it follows the prompt very well so
that's why you are a winner this week my
friend
um congratulations you get that
challenge winner role in the discord
server
you're going to be seen by the 13 000
plus
3d artists in the server the link is in
the description come join us guys
come join the 3d challenge i think we
had a hundred
and uh if one of the mods can confirm it
here i think we had
definitely a hundred plus submissions so
you know if you guys are winning these
things you you're doing a really good
job and these are getting harder and
harder
to judge because the renders are just
better and better every single time
and we're coming up on a year guys a
year of weekly challenges
and i want to do something special for
that i want to put out maybe
maybe a video or something it could be
very fun
124 submissions yep
is uh is absolutely incredible
so congrats congrats to our first winner
and moving on to the second winner here
is no other than
one dead duck with this beautiful
render of an abandoned city again guys
following the prompt here really good
use of
the the prompt overgrown um
you know last of us two vibes all the
way
fantastic game if you guys ever played
last of us too my goodness it's
incredible
yeah straight out of last of us two in
seattle um
so you're following the prompt really
well here
and your render quality is through the
roof 10 out of 10.
there's a story going on you have
character and you have the dog going
and these people are surviving in this
world and your framing is
fantastic your lighting is fantastic i
like the streaks that you have coming
across
the image here in the sun you see like
how the sun is catching the grass there
and different parts of the of the grass
here of this field
are being illuminated in strips and that
gives you depth
into in the image here um
yeah you're using like kind of like a
side
front lit uh i'd say side lit definitely
side lit
kind of lighting set up here that looks
very nice the
my only gripe with this one is the birds
on the top right
i feel like they're a little too dark
they might have a little bit more motion
blur
and they would probably fade in
to the fog a little bit more i feel like
um but my goodness yeah congrats one
dead duck man
you were winning these a lot i'm really
happy with all the cool work you've been
doing man
so keep it up congratulations you get
the challenge winner roll this week
hang on to it all right guys moving on
for the third winner of the weekly
challenge
this week is
manual manuel
dude this is freaking cool
so again you are
following the prompt very well this is
definitely an overgrown
um environment here i love your camera
angle
and i love your wide and uh your wide
angle lens here that you're using you're
really really
utilizing that in a really cool way and
also if you look closely
written in blood on this pillar
it says it's really tiny for me but it
says uh
something along the lines of they can
hear you be quiet they can hear you or
something like that
um super creepy so
there's your story and then you have a
really intense blood splatter on the
side of this pillar
you're working with that story man
that's the next level can you find a
story element
in your render that's really what we
want to go for we want to tell stories
we don't want to just do renders
because renders look cool because who
cares at a certain point
once you have enough cool renders it's
like all right i get it but
once you start adding story to it that's
the next level guys that's the next
level
dude your textures are crazy your
lighting is crazy your composition is
amazing
um so congratulations manuel for winning
this week's weekly challenge
i think this is the first time you've
won a weekly challenge
and same for um utkarsh this is the
first time
you've won a weekly challenge and uh
i think we have one more person we have
two more
two more spots here two more winners
and we have one of those people
i believe is a first time weekly
challenge winner as well i'm just
excited that we're getting more people
doing this
more people winning these challenges
guys
and it is none other than edward
h bam with this one right here dude this
looks so good so good
your render quality and your lighting
are 10 out of 10 dude
you're doing everything super well here
you're working with some fog here
um you have some dripping foliage and
leafs and whatnot some ivy
um i love your composition
i love the story you're telling with
this render um
[Music]
what the heck neesee pc says use the
force harry
um that's a gandalf quote for you guys
what the heck dude that's so random but
i appreciate the super chat
that's hilarious um i love it man
this is very beautiful a very very
beautiful render
you should be proud because you got the
challenge winner roll
this week congratulations edward h
you're killing it
all right and finally
you know this one was this one was a mix
up i went back and forth there was
literally like five other renders
that was that we're going to win um
it was between these five renders for me
but i think at the end of the day it
came down
to mr red of paw it's a
very ambitious short film dude you
straight up made a short film
for overgrown and i couldn't be more
excited about this dude this is crazy
check this out
like i'm going to let this go
there is sound and music if you guys go
on the discord you can watch it in its
full glory i just
don't know if i can play it on the
stream because if it's copywritten music
you know i can't i can't do that
so maybe let me know if you guys do
video submissions in the future
if i can play the music let's loop it
one more time isn't this crazy now you
guys can see here if this was a
meta-human
it might look a little more realistic so
that's just a use of uh
of how we can use these metahumans in
the future here but this is cool like
i really dig this freaking
nasty organic tentacle looking
thing going through your destruction is
really cool your animation style is
really cool
your environments are really cool your
lighting is awesome and it's getting
creepier and creepier
it reminds me of akira you know
you guys ever seen akira yeah prototype
that game too but man congratulations
reddi paw
and to the rest of the winners you guys
are getting the challenge winner roll
this week
but we ain't done because i got a few
honorable mentions to get to
there's been a lot of freaking cool
renders and i can't just leave it here
so let me see if i can uh if i can do
this
so first off um
[Music]
legion like this one dude this one is
sick
i really love this render uh i also love
that it fills up the full frame here
it looks really nice i love it so much
your render quality is great
yeah man um it's a little hard to tell
that there's a knight
back there and i feel like there's a lot
of uh
empty space in the foreground here i
think you can crop that out
but other than that dude really good
stuff
i love this render so much
and so you guys asking if i have a
discord yes i do have a discord the link
is in the description
go for it join these community
challenges they're really fun
um next up we got mr hans hauser
with this really incredible render the
render quality is 10 out of 10.
the only reason this didn't win
is because i don't get that overgrown
feeling from it um
sim like simply put yeah it just doesn't
seem
overgrown to me but it's an incredible
render
an incredible render 10 out of 10 for
sure really cool story there
you got a little cricket in the
foreground i love it very nice
uh joel dude you came close too man you
came very close to winning this one
super cool render um joel actually gave
me a little bit of stats on his render
once he finished it he said it was 10
000 samples um gi clamp set to two
uh we were wondering would it would it
be faster if it was set to one
i don't know
but yeah this is a really cool one i
like your uh
i like your layout here it's very nice
very good composition
you know you got the cross right in the
center frame there
and you know like i said this is getting
harder and harder
to choose these winners because
literally every single one of these
could be winners so i have to just get
really specific
with the reason i'm choosing these
things and and and it makes it really
hard it makes it really really hard
i don't want to open it up to 10 winners
i want to keep it five
you know it makes it i think more of an
accomplishment if you get to that top
five but if you guys are in the
honorable mentions here you're very
close
you're right there we got bobby riggs
this was another one that almost won
dude this was this was in my top five or
i guess top eight for like the longest
time
and uh i think i made it even a top six
it's really cool very well well rendered
well framed well shot
you have a little story going too it
says uh you want to play a game
and i think the only reason i didn't
choose this one
was because potentially like the other
the other render with like be quiet they
can still hear you
you know that render that story element
was a little bit
more original to me personally
than like the saw angle do you want to
play a game
so with this one it's like do you have a
story element
and is your story element a bit more
original
so that's that's crazy too you know
that's like the added level to it
but yeah dude so close fantastic render
uh the game factory another one that was
like super close to winning
very very close to winning man it's very
cool your render quality was very nice
the only thing that i felt about this
one
it was a little difficult to tell what
is what
from this angle like i i feel like you
need a bit more
separation between foreground mid-ground
and background it all kind of blends
together
now you have some fog here but i feel
like if you would have done some low
lying ground fog that could have helped
if you had things poking out a little
closer
to the character that could have helped
a little bit more but it's just
it's a little difficult to tell what is
what um
it's not a it's not a bad thing it's a
fantastic render in almost one again you
know it's just if i was to get really
nitpicky with it but
i love it man it's really good super
solid work
maybe you could use color maybe you
could use color to help separate
the the foreground in the background or
something or
yeah it's a tough one because the
lighting is pretty even throughout it's
overcast lighting
maybe if the character in the foreground
was wearing
uh like a red
a red costume or yellow or something
something to have it stand out or just
even white
like the coke dispenser that this
person's standing on is white that
really stands out
so maybe you could do the character in
white to have them pop out and work in
silhouettes a little bit
um you can make the background darker
you make the foreground brighter too
um you know these are all different
things that you can use to have the
character
and have your art piece you know be a
bit more defined
foreground mid-ground background the fog
is a classic use you know
um what else
yeah let's move on let's move on we have
a couple more ronin
this one is super cool man it reminds me
of dead space
that's one of my favorite games of all
time your render quality is really nice
and it's just freaking overgrown city up
in this space station
it looks very cool i like your camera
angle i like how the leading lines kind
of lead you to that
to the end of the hallway maybe it would
have been cool to have like a
brighter light source towards the end of
the hallway to kind of lead the eye a
little bit it's just a little dark but
hey you know that's that's the point
it's a scary sci-fi horror
kind of piece and i dig it man i think
it's a really really good stuff
congratulations to you um
pars v3 another one
that nearly almost won dude freaking
crazy
this one's really good the the render
quality is fantastic
it's certainly overgrown um camera angle
is pretty darn good
your attention to detail is solid uh i
think the only thing with this one is
just you know
robots in the forest overgrown robots in
the forest i've seen that
vibe before certainly not to say that i
hadn't seen
you know the vibe that the winners had
it's just you know there i think there
was a big number of robots in the forest
on this one
so i was trying to go for like what
stood out to me what felt a bit
different what felt a bit unique
but don't let that get you down man
because this was
in my top eight for a while so
congratulations dude it's a great render
it is a fantastic
render all right moving on oren cloud is
next
this is beautiful this is very very
beautiful
it's very different speaking about
different is very different very unique
very cool style too it reminds me of
princess mononoke
yeah the lighting is very cool um
very studio studio ghibli kind of vibe
here
i dig it a lot you'll be very proud of
this one it's a good one
very very good noodle noodle chon
dude this one again for me this one was
close to winning two i
really love the vibe here i love the
lens choice you have
it's beautiful it's like you just peeked
into this little uh
outcropping in the forest and you found
this
soldier you know sitting here kind of
reminds me of
the movie stalker if you guys have ever
seen stalker it's a really good one
um but man your colors here are
beautiful
i would want to play this game this is
absolutely beautiful man
i dig it so much keep it up solid stuff
else steady is next this one's crazy it
almost
looks real um
it kind of reminds me of a pokemon card
there was like a caterpie pokemon card
that looked
super real and mossy or it was like a
weedle or something
um and i just realized that right now
but it's cool dude overgrown robot in
the forest gotta love it
you got the fog going off into the
background and a really nice lighting
setup on this guy in the foreground i
dig it
freaking sweet
little robot is next you got your bonsai
tree
chilling um in this little
like uh i don't know interior setup
i love it i love your your textures are
solid your lighting is solid
it's a very fun render i like it a lot
man congratulations
keep it up jack the hack is next
i love those full screen renders
filling up the whole frame i love it
this one's cool
reminds me of the last of us too as well
freaking sick oh you got the spores
taken over
taking over the work setup i don't know
like what
i'm wondering what website is this dude
on you got mushrooms going around the
screen
but i love it dude i freaking love it it
looks like it's being hit by a
flashlight
and he's kind of lit by the monitor in
the front but he's been hit with a
flashlight from the side
i love it dude all those mushrooms and
spores that's a lot of detail work there
man congrats
congratulations on the detail work you
didn't miss out on that
uh devin devin's next this one's cool
really good composition great lighting
great use of fog and atmosphere i think
there's a little photoshop filter on
here
i'm wondering if these are some ian
hubert photo scans because it looks like
the grass is photo scanned and the
leaves are photoscanned
hard to say maybe you did it on your own
but i really like the vibe
super solid creed is next
this one this one just spoke to me
because of uh the lighting and the
render quality
and the fog of course um
yeah i just i really like the render
quality the lighting and the fog
it's really good um cool idea too you
got it in the bathroom
overgrown bathtub super creepy that's a
vibe for sure man i dig it
billy is next this one's sick dude this
one came really close to winning too
could easily have been one of the
winners um
i i freaking love this one is super cool
i love how you used uh different
basically to get this look here what you
did is
is kind of chose different still frames
from an animation and you overlaid them
on top of each other and you give it a
really cool marble look
this one is sick man
jeff yes jeff try the challenge
try the challenge we're gonna come up
with a prompt for you guys pretty soon
here
i'm excited very excited for it
um next up we got pasta and then we got
one more after this i just like your
lighting here
i am a sucker for top lit stuff um
i love it yeah i just i just love it
good rendering quality
fun lighting super moody i dig it and
finally
we have i think the render that made me
laugh the hardest
out of this entire thing and that's
owen with this freaking render dude
look at their faces they're like oh my
god
what is this abomination and the dude in
the back is just like
it's like i need a haircut now i love it
it just made me it made me laugh it made
the mods laugh it made everyone laugh
dude this one's great
i love the barber they're both just like
oh my god
francesco he's like dude what is this
oh man that is awesome
that's freaking awesome and no i didn't
notice that my art was in the background
of the freaking top lit render
oh my god it is it's the one that me and
sam did
that's hilarious i didn't notice that
but hey guys um i kind of have a
uh that kind of so myself
and the mods on the crate with clint
server
we made an instagram for you guys and
it's going to house
all of the winners of the weekly
challenges
down from the first challenge all the
way up to the most recent
so what we're doing it's instagram.com
createwithclint
i should probably include it in the
description from now on
um we're kind of doing a soft launch
right now because
we're not caught up yet we're releasing
five images
every single day so basically five
winners for one challenge
every day um and it's just it's a
feature account it's a way to feature
all of your guys's art i wanna build it
up as
as much as possible and once we get
caught up
you know we're gonna be posting i think
the plan right now is to post
one image a day for the whole week uh
it's gonna be each one's gonna be a
winner
and i'd like to do some stories for
honorable mentions and stuff
and i really want to shout out sotomonte
and ronan
for helping uh build this instagram
account
you know sotomonte is the one doing the
posting right now and ronan was the one
who reached out to all of you guys all
the winners to ask hey is it cool if we
do this with your art
and basically all of you guys said yes
so check it out
you know it's a really cool
inspirational place to look at all of
the winners of this
of the weekly challenges we're going to
get caught up very soon probably within
the next couple months
um and then i'll blast it more you know
once we're caught up but
go check it out give it a follow uh and
get inspired
guys and enjoy the freaking 3d
challenges they're great we're going to
figure out the next one right now
the link's in the description so what do
you guys want to do what are y'all
trying to do this week
um you know we we got a lot of options
usually i leave it up to you guys ooh
anime
dude anime is a good one yo anime is a
super good one
um that's definitely gonna be in the
straw poll
yeah let me uh let me get this straw
poll going
i'm gonna go down the list and we'll see
what we can get um
[Music]
i'll pull let's create a poll
hmm did they change straw poll it looks
different now
anime what else
uh self portrait are we at the self
portrait yeah self portrait it'd be
fitting
waiting for the stream funeral dude
that's rough music oh
music that's a good one anime
yeah that's a good one i like anime
human tropical portrait yeah self i mean
self portrait feels
feels right at least to be on the straw
poll on
on the uh let's see
um
what else do we got guys vr
a city vaporwave
oh vaporwave interesting very
interesting
deep ocean avatar the last airbender
best show ever
well we did ocean didn't we didn't we do
underwater
we did underwater last year
um interior middle age
cyberpunk i think we did um
we didn't we do cyberpunk yeah we did
aquatic
rage oh what if we did in an emotion
um feeling deep space we did
planet
um superhero
music yeah music i'm not i'm down for
music
i think it could be a fun one but did we
do music already
i can't remember
ah cypo melancholy is similar to um
sentimental item almost
mexican revolution please
it's very specific full vfx shot it
would be fun
um
airships dude airship would be sweet
psychedelic trip
um food
is a tough one sword
fight world war ii crypto
spaceship steampunk we did that we did
that
two weeks ago steampunk maybe it was
last week's
it was a tough one zen still alive i
think we did still life
illusion
no one's cyberpunk
i swear we did cyberpunk though end of
an era oh that's
interesting end of an era is very
interesting
hmm balance that's interesting too
vintage sternum rubs
bizarre huh interesting these are some
good ones guys banana
phobia that's not bad
hmm neon i think we did neon
maybe all right uh
japanese culture phobia is pretty good
all right let's let's try it phobia
so we have anime self-portrait and
phobia
um
oh speed that's a good one dude speed is
really good okay we got four
um i'm calling it from here
thank you guys for your suggestions i'm
about to post a link
okay um i'm just gonna make this
this poll here real quick
all right
what's the weekly challenge anime
self-portrait phobia or speed
all right guys here it is the link will
be pinned
so go here go to the straw poll link
that i just posted
i'll give you guys about a minute or two
yo alex windows 95 windows 95
screen saver is a really good one
definitely
uh that is that is fantastic
the polls already up so not this week
but dude if you're here next week
that sounds amazing that sounds like a
lot of fun
all right so i'm looking at the results
here keeping them hidden for now
and we'll see what we get
okay all right guys so
right now to all you guys voting i
better see
199 submissions next week
all right 205 submissions like 208
submissions next week i better see him
i'll give this another 30 seconds the
winner seems very clear to me
the winner seems very clear any guesses
as to what you think will win
speed phobia anime or self-portrait
yeah y'all are right it's speed guys
y'all have spoken
bam that is it speed is the one
we're doing it uh i'm excited
i'm i'm very excited for this one should
be very very cool
um this is one that like i am a
sucker for anything fast
i remember i was in vegas and i got the
opportunity to fly
in a stunt plane and i actually got to
pilot the stunt plane
and dogfight a friend
with like laser tag but up in up in the
sky
and it was the craziest thing i've ever
done in my life my friend
in the in his other plane he passed out
he hit
uh he had eight g's and passed out so
they'd turn his plane
over to have the blood rush back to his
head i hit
seven g's which basically felt like
you know uh an immense pressure against
my body
and my vision just went like this you
know like you did the vignette filter
and it went down to like my vision was
just my eyes were wide open
but all i could see was this and then it
went dark
my eyes were open but i couldn't see
anything it was just darkness
i was like oh i guess this is what it's
like to pass out
that's not as scary as i thought it was
going to be and
i didn't pass out my vision came back
i was still mentally there when you
fully pass out
you go like huh what happened where am i
you're very confused like when ren
passed out
in the smash bros tournament
um but yeah that's gonna be a fun one
guys speed is the challenge
so create a render that has some speed
to it
some motion you know motion blur will
probably be in your render i assume
um have fun with this one guys have a
blast
i'm very excited
but man that was an awesome an awesome
stream
to cap it out to cap it out guys
let's go ahead and hop into unreal
engine
and uh and see if
we can't get our metahuman in here and
then we'll call it a day
thank you guys for joining me it's been
a blast
man we uh we had like 1500 people
um at one point that's pretty crazy
that is pretty insane
that's a record this is an all-time
record guys
i wanted to get ren or peter up in here
to make some faces with me but it was a
little too late i had the idea
like friday night last night so
soon i won't get those guys back for
y'all it'll be a fun one
thanks for all the subscriptions you
guys are awesome
let's hop into our table and vase scene
this is just something
that i've been messing around
in that way all of our shaders don't
have to load
skying or sky sky king thank you for
joining
yeah uh it's the first one you've caught
you joined at the end but that's okay
man
all good definitely join the challenge
it's going to be fun
you want to do that the link is in the
description it's to my discord server go
down to the discord server
um on the left the top left you're going
to find the weekly challenge
channels all right and under
weekly challenge you'll see the prompt
which will be speed
read those rules guys please read the
rules we don't want to we want to
accept as many of these uh challenges as
possible
you know some of you guys don't post
proof you need to post proof in the
right way so just make sure you read
the rules um if you're doing this for
the first time
and hey if you're doing this for the
third time still read the rules you know
it helps out a little bit
guys these subscriptions are popping off
that's awesome
thank you thank you make sure you get
that bell
yeah hit that little bell notification
yeah boy tanmay
good to see you thank you have a good
one
um have i ever made any blender
tutorials for my channel
no i have not i have referenced blender
clips
and i have uh in in the one
[Music]
where i break down my pen and my knife
in one of my edited videos there um
i i use a little bit of reference to
blender and show you guys how you can do
some things that are pretty universal
but i don't get i don't really dig into
it
shout outs to sodamonte for recording
those blender clips for me
um i appreciate them very much
i do have a gigabyte connection yes yes
i do have a gigabyte connection
amazing i love it att fiber
what's the weekly challenge the weekly
challenge
is speed
and that's actually a good thing i'll
pin it
okay so you guys might recognize this
scene
when i was messing around with uh
with steve last week we made a cool
unreal engine
like radar scene if you guys want to
watch that
this is last week's video but let's uh
let's see if we can open up this
metahuman and see
what it looks like um let's go to
content
let's make a new level i'll just call it
um metahuman
test
i'll hop in
and it looks like i need a floor
so let's search for a floor
and i need a skylight
so let's type in skylight
let's type in a light source we need
a directional let's see
directional light should be our
sun maybe i'm getting this wrong maybe i
go to lights
skylight why is am i not seeing anything
uh
directional point light spotlight
rectangular
skylight
uh
sky sphere
i need i'm pretty new to unreal engine
spherical reflection capture sky sphere
yeah directional light that we can
[Music]
be
removable
add sky atmosphere in clouds
sky atmosphere
and clouds volumetric cloud
no sky atmosphere
remove the bp sky
well i could hear here which i could
probably do
um let's go to
remove the sky sphere if you want to add
a sky atmosphere
so this is my sky i'm described not sure
why it's not
let's go to our levels
starter content
maps starter map
whoa
i mean this works certainly works
let's just drop in this meta human and
see what the heck oh we're compiling
1500 shaders we don't want to do that
minimal default
screw it all right let's uh
let's see if we can bring this in export
go my export settings change it to
unreal engine
and
[Music]
export
get those f's ready i might be lagging
here
we'll see
all right guys we're still going
um
[Music]
lagging like crazy
this might be it
[Music]
oh did you get lunch
i'm almost done
all right y'all are we alive
yes please
so can you guys even hear me
i'm back oh my goodness
dismiss dismiss audio's back but not the
video
i'm here guys i'm here um
but it's crunching i don't know how this
is gonna go
hang in there guys
oh boy
yeah it's definitely a lesson not to
compile shaders
on the stream
oh did it work
yeah cpu definitely at 100.
all right where's where's glenda
she down there
where are you glenda
lights uh maybe she's like way
down here
i don't know guys
this might be it glenda might have
broken everything
um i don't know where she is she's
probably running around in the scene
somewhere
i cannot find glenda oh it'll be fun to
where's waldo like a full
a full cg where's waldo that could be
fun
i don't know this might be it guys
i think i have to call it thank you
glenda successfully broke
broke the stream but guys you got your
uh
here let me let me just see if i can
force quit this
give me one moment so i can at least say
goodbye
unreal we're gonna end that task
okay
are we back
cpu is still at 100 percent
oh all right guys
the video's back my cpu is at 100
percent
uh but i think i'm gonna call it yep
we're back now i think we're back
cpu is uh is looking like a hot 39
percent
but guys thank you so much for joining
me that was awesome
we'll try that again next time with
shaders compiled ahead of time
my cpu is cranking up again but y'all
i'ma bounce get on that weekly challenge
it's gonna be good one
thank you guys for joining me i really
appreciate you and uh
yeah i'll be seeing you guys soon see
you next week
peace out guys later
[Music]
[Music]
you